he manages Bryce Harper which is one of
the biggest offseason signings to say
the least in major league baseball and
I'm pleased to have him on the show and
I'm not just saying that because we both
have parents from Bensonhurst Brooklyn
he's Gabe Kapler the manager the
Philadelphia Phillies how are you game
how are you I'm doing great yeah my
parents are from Brooklyn - Gabe yeah
that's kind of cool it's it's nice how
those things connect people like it is
that my folks said they still have two
thick New York accents it sounds like
they never left Brooklyn yeah I love my
mom tell stories about about Bensonhurst
kind of cool it's back in the day yeah
back in the day a good good conversation
with mom yeah I know my mom and my dad
would always tell me about watching
Jackie Robinson play and it's Jackie
Robinson day and in Major League
Baseball you got your 42 ready tonight I
do it's every every time I've been a
part of Jackie Robinson day and I've
seen my Jersey hanging in the locker
with number 42 and no name on the back
gives me chills no matter where I've
been no matter what clubs I've been with
where in the country I've been it always
makes me feel like I'm part of something
special and really lucky to have even
witnessed Jackie Robinson play in video
I mean what a what a stud and what an
honor to be associated with Major League
Baseball on a day like today yeah and
taking on the Mets - you got syndergaard
coming into your house and we'll hit
that in a second so again it's a Jackie
Roberts a day Major League Baseball
it'll be a fun day to watch games and of
course reflect as well what what has it
been like getting Bryce Hart Harper
acclimated to the Philadelphia scene or
has he just done that all on his own
Gaye really he's a pretty prepared
pretty diligent individual super intense
nothing catches him off guard he was
prepared for the biggest spotlight and
it was a pretty big spotlight on opening
day here in Philadelphia and then headed
to Washington DC for his return to that
city and he's just managed all of the
emotion and channeled it and just been a
great baseball player and clubhouse
leader for a since he's been here yeah
and then Franco
and Hoskins have been raking as well how
how it does just him being there
clubhouse in the lineup how does it
affect everybody around him so far here
well I think in the clubhouse that makes
us a stronger unit he doesn't feel the
need to stand up in front of the group
and be a rah-rah guy you know if you can
just fit in and and lead with his play
on the field which has been really
really good it's not just the offensive
production that we've all seen but it's
also the base running the outfield play
has been great and the energy level the
intensity really sets the tone for our
club so Bryce has been great and really
happy to happen well we had a guy who
you know very well and Dave Roberts on
the show and he told us about talking to
Harper and during the free agency
process and described sort of like an
Ocean's eleven type scene in Vegas just
going to see him and what was it like
being part of that free agency process
the meetings with him I was pretty
exciting because you could kind of you
could sense that this was going to be a
part of somebody's book someday part of
the story and a very small piece of the
story but one that's really important
and so you know the recruiting process
for all of the clubs involved was a
pretty intense one there's a lot of work
put in and at the end of the day this
was Bryce's decision about where he
wanted to be for the long haul
choosing a club for 13 years is a real
commitment and it's certainly not just
about the money although I know I
understand why people tend to think that
when you make a commitment to a city for
13 years it means I want to be here I
don't want to be anywhere else and I'm
prepared to dig in and and be a part of
something special here for a very long
time so did you think at any point in
time that he wasn't coming to Philly I
think there's always that that doubt and
certainly he had many suitors and great
opportunities and I thought that he
would make the decision that was best
for him and Kayla and his family and I
think that's exactly what happened did
you go to Vegas were you part of that
whole scene - I did and it was it was a
really incredible experience he's I knew
he had some important decisions to make
and
Philadelphia abilities had some pretty
big decisions to make and so it felt it
felt intense and at the same time it I
felt very honored to be a part of it
Judy does he have a hangover type set up
like Tyson in Vegas best you can tell
any animals or anything like that no no
no no Tigers no animals that I said I
was aware of but it was a nice
conference room and some really good
conversation and in a really nice hotel
so really really cool very good gabe
kapler met Phillies manager here on the
Rich Eisen show you could wave a wand
and make a rule change you could tell
Commissioner Manfred I want this done
and he says done what's that rule change
for you I don't have one for you rich I
can tell you that I really like the
strategy of the National League it's
it's a lot of fun I mean I love the the
gamesmanship and I love the the tactical
decisions that go on in the game so kind
of like having the pitcher hit and at
the same time I think it would be cool
to have you know a BH and get one more
guy who can bash on the roster I you
know when it comes to rules rule changes
I kind of feel like it's the
responsibility of the managers around
the game to just be really good under
those circumstances under the new
circumstances so that's how I think
about it all right what it didn't let me
ask you about some of the changes that
have been made what do you think of the
idea that you you might have one day the
inability to change pitchers because the
pitcher hasn't faced a minimum number of
batters out of the bullpen yet the way I
think about it is is immediately pretty
strategically it means that we have to
have guys that can go through multiple
multiple batters on our roster it means
that we need to find the guys who are
strongest through three batters instead
of you know matching up for one batter
at a time and it's kind of a I look at
it as a good challenge and a different
kind of challenge but it just changes
the way you manage a baseball game and
everybody so one thing that I've always
said is if it's if it's raining on one
side of the field it's raining on the
other so if we all have the same rules
then it
becomes a race for who can be most
strategic within the contract of those
rules so I don't I don't form an opinion
they thought oh I really like this one
or oh I really don't like this one and
instead I just immediately focused my
attention and our attention on being
good under the the current circumstance
all right then let me try it this way
Gabe Kapler if I had to wave a wand and
Rob Manfred said done I would get rid of
the shift I can't stand it I'm seeing
somebody like Chris Davis go old 453 and
I think the shift has a lot to do with
it the the the the rope that he hit to
break up that Street got on if you saw
it I mean it sailed over the head of
somebody that was right there in short
right centerfield it drives me crazy
would you have a problem if that went
away I I don't think it's I don't think
it drives me crazy and in the same way
it does you I understand the passion
around around the ship and at the same
time if the rule was changed and you
know we had to position our infielders
traditionally I wouldn't have a super
hard time with that either
I just don't have you know I think part
of the job of being an entertainer on
television being an entertainer on the
radio is to be very opinionated about
things like that I think the job of a
major league manager a major league
executive is to do just the opposite and
it doesn't mean that we don't feel the
feelings but immediately shift those
feelings to how do I do the best job I
can possibly do under these conditions
and so I'm not I'm not taking in the
position here that I don't feel an
initial reaction to a new rule what I'm
saying is it's my responsibility to
quickly [ __ ] how do I do a good job
under the current construction well I
don't paint me with a broad media brush
Gabe don't do that I mean you know like
don't just lump me in with everybody
else
I mean I'm Debra you're you're you're
you're a super sharp guy Lou thank you
doing this for a really really long time
and your job is to have strong opinion
well no I do
that one I do I really do I'm not just
you know I don't make anything up but I
just it just seems to me you know I want
to see more action I mean we started
this conversation with with Jackie
Robinson and for a great reason you know
I mean the split screen was was invented
because he stole bases and I'm not
saying people don't steal bases anymore
but it just doesn't seem to be much
action anymore there's just the the the
doubles and triples and the it just
doesn't seem to that the game has
changed and I just look at the shift and
I blame that
okay so I'll give you since since you
you conjure up an image of Jackie for me
yes I I will I will Express one strong
opinion for you thank you I really
enjoyed as a place I really enjoyed as a
player the ability to have contact at
the plate with the catcher and I really
enjoyed as a player the ability to have
contact with the middle infielders at
second base
so those those are both things that I
think are we're really exciting about
baseball and kind of made the game I
don't know a little little more rugged a
little little rougher a little bit more
old-school so those are things that I I
kind of miss about the game how that
well cuz you're built like a brick house
I mean that helps that helps you know I
mean that held that absolutely helps in
that regard
what is your workout regimen what is it
it's it's different now now I have it no
I can't just be a manager what do you
mean eat whatever I want in the
clubhouse and come on go for it go for a
run come on back in my day and yours
when you played you know managers didn't
look like you they didn't you know they
just sit there and they they just you
know they they eat sunflower seeds and
sit on their butts and didn't work out
very much
I will say this about our staff in
Philadelphia our our entire coaching
staff yes a they do a really really good
job of getting after it prior to the
time that the players arrived at the
ballpark these guys seem like they're
constantly sweating so it's not just the
work that they do in the coach's room
you know analyzing video looking at
spray charts studying the opposition but
it's also the physical conditioning that
they do and I think the reason that's
notable
[Music]
is because I think that you know players
want to know that we're all in this
together and that everybody's willing to
work as hard as they are or harder to
support them and I think doing some of
the things that they do is actually a
good example so I'm proud of our staff
for those things okay so when was the
last time you had a simple sugar Gabe
like legitimately like a skittle or
something like that what was the last
time you know I know you'll probably not
believe this but I ate more chocolate
covered almond and spring training than
I probably like any sweets that I have
in my entire life I it was like one
large cup of chocolate almonds after the
other all the way through spring
training so sound coating of milk
chocolate around them and okay that was
pretty a pretty good binge for me I will
accept that I've got two more questions
for you Gabe Kapler Phillies manager
here you played a game yesterday how
much was the Masters on in the clubhouse
locker room it was on quite a bit we
have a couple of coaches who follow
closely I know some players were really
excited about Tiger I can tell you I
didn't watch a stroke of it okay but it
was it was definitely on in the
background and guys we're talking about
it and this is this is not to to change
the topic but with the Mets coming in I
just felt like there were some things
that we had so we have to attend of
course makes sense that's totally
understandable last thing for you to
Gabe you are one of nine individuals to
be fortunate enough to say you were on
the field when the Red Sox broke the
curse in 2004 Francona kept you in after
being a pinch runner kept you on the
field were you surprised that you were
on kept on the field did you lobby for
whatwhat's this story is there any story
behind that I think I was not a I mean I
was not
one of the best 9 guys on that on that
club right I think what happened in that
particular case was we had a pretty
strict platoon going so I would bet I
would bat against left-handed pitchers
trot Nixon with that against right into
pitchers and then there's a pretty
consistent base running switch toward
the end of game for defensive switch
toward BG&E games and so that's why I
found myself on the field at that time I
felt really lucky and the fact that you
don't believed in me at that time was
was pretty special for me and man I I
honestly just feel blessed over the
whole thing yeah I don't know I would
have lobbied for it maybe that's why I
brought it up that way I loved it I was
just kind of envisioning now in the in
the managers position a player coming
and be like hey please put me on the
field yeah sure no problem go ahead I
don't know maybe the analytics match up
you never know I'm just hey thanks for
the call Gabe I hope it's the first of
many here to the show really enjoyed our
chat and then it's been a long time so I
appreciate it you bet right back at you
that's Gabe Kapler Phillies manager for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app